what up guys welcome to the just hurry
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the sit down where I bring on different
guests to talk about the cultural issues
of today before we start make sure you
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos so
today's guest I actually first saw you
when you when you covered me
um it was like a couple months back I
think but you you have a channel you
almost have a million subscribers on
YouTube it's the black conservative
perspective how long have you been on
YouTube well I've been doing YouTube
about three three years now
um so I started back in August of 2020
uh after or during the BLM protest that
really made me upset that this was
happening in our country to destruction
the violence uh behind a lie and I
decided that I wanted to speak out and
to put my opinion out there to the world
in regards to what I think about what's
going on politically uh what's going on
socially what's going on culturally and
uh that's why I started my channel and I
had no clue that it would
um you know get to the point where it's
at but you know here we are yeah you're
on it you're like always one of the
first ones I see when a story breaks
yeah you got to be on top of it I mean
this is when you cover news CNN doesn't
take a break Fox News doesn't take a
break MSNBC don't take a break so I feel
like I can't take a break if I'm trying
to compete yeah so you said you started
it during the BLM protests like do you
can you say what city you're in um well
at the time I was in North Carolina okay
um so being in North Carolina I believe
we had some protests in Charlotte
um the city that I'm from Greensboro
High Point they had some protests as
well too just in general just seeing
what was happening in the country in
regards to destruction the violence and
understanding my own experience as a
black person dealing with police also
having police in my family
um I just felt that the narrative that
was being pushed was very divisive and
also not correct I think that the
realities that they were pushing in
regards to police wanting to basically
hunt down and kill unarmed black men
indiscriminately was ridiculous right
being a black person
um I know that's not true and I've had
multiple interactions with police it was
just that and then a whole bunch of
other stuff going on as well too
obviously you had the election coming up
and um you know being a more
conservative person you know in Black it
was not common to see black people you
know speak out and say things that don't
go along with the progressive slash
liberal agenda so I just started my
channel just as a way to put out my
thoughts and again I had no clue that it
would become what it is I had no
intentions on starting a channel that
would you know basically cover news
every single day it was more of uh hey
here's my opinion on this
um this is why I think about it and then
it just kind of picked up and then when
it picked up I was like oh well I guess
this is this is is my faith I'm curious
what did you do before YouTube so before
YouTube I worked in financial services
so I was an investor no wonder you're
conservative yeah yeah I mean that's
that's kind of that's what happens I
mean when I went to college
um I was always like a more socially
conservative person because I was raised
in the South uh two-parent household you
know grew up in a church and stuff like
that so always more conservative
socially even though my family was a
conservative politically but you know I
went to uh college at UNC Chapel Hill
and yeah I mean you get essentially
indoctrinated in college right they they
pushed the the liberal slash woke agenda
especially about black folks and
systemic racism and all this other stuff
um so there were moments in college
where I definitely felt like I was
having a lot of questions right I felt
like I was definitely bought into the
agenda
um but once I kind of got back into the
real world started working started
working in financial services understand
training how money Works how taxes work
how the real world actually works paying
more attention to the news yeah I
definitely was like yeah I'm I'm
conservative
I'm conservative so yeah working in the
financial services industry will do that
to you for sure yeah I think my dad is
saying it was like if you're if you
aren't liberal in college you don't have
a heart and if you aren't conservative
after 30 you don't have a brain yeah
exactly no I I 100 agree with that I
think that you know college definitely
will challenge you if you're a
conservative and you go to one of these
these these liberal indoctrination
centers that's basically what they are
that is what will happen right that you
will definitely start to question
yourself for sure what is the craziest
thing you heard a professor say in
college I can't think of anything
specifically because it was like seven
years ago but I think one of the things
that really kind of transformed my
opinion in college from what was
happening was I took this Sociology
class and there was a professor who
played a documentary I think it's called
13 or something like that the
documentary about like slavery and Jim
Crow and a bunch of up and uh he tried
so hard to push this idea that as a
black person that it's hard to get ahead
in this country that you don't have the
same opportunities as white people and
that systemic racism is holding you down
and I just I just rejected that like
almost on a daily basis in class like I
would raise my hand and just give
rebuttals to the things they were saying
just using my own personal experience
about how you know as a black person you
can start a business just like anybody
else right you can go out and get a good
job and you can be successful just like
anybody else as long as you work hard
and you apply yourself and you make good
decisions and you take risks like you
can achieve great things in this country
and um I think that's one of the kind of
light bulb moments that happened to me
in college uh my last two years where I
just got tired of these professors
pushing this stuff down my throat and I
was just like okay I'm I'm gonna like
actually
um you know speak out against it and to
push back as a black person that hey I
don't buy into this yeah was it was it
women it's always like the chicks no
this actually was a dude he was a he was
a liberal white guy okay but but I've
had my fair share of like you know Ultra
Progressive like white women you know
professors as well too so that happens
yeah my professor like told me that
because I was an economics major but
like my marketing Professor was telling
me that basically they would raise
prices in the lower income neighborhoods
because like they were racist and
whatever and I was just like you realize
it's because in the lower income
neighborhoods they have to have more
like security like it's like yeah yeah
and it's like people steal more
typically so yeah and I'm like everyone
steals from the Walmart down the street
everyone did in my school so I'm like
that that one is high prices too so yeah
I just covered a story
um about how Nike is closing their
retail store in Portland and the reason
why is because of theft you have
thousands of businesses that are are
doing a mass Exodus from these big
liberal cities that have become soft on
crime and then the woke activists turn
around and they cry racism oh it's
racist yeah that is that a business is
leaving because they're being you know
there's so much theft yeah well and it's
so funny because it's always these
liberals that don't live in the
crime-ridden areas that tell them to be
soft I'm crying yeah they don't they
don't they don't live anywhere close uh
yeah I'm like I don't like they don't
see it they don't have to deal with it
and it's not just that issue either it's
the issue of immigration too when you
look at what's happening at the border
with the Border crisis oh yeah um the
Liberals only started to care when the
Border was bought to the sanctuary
cities like New York and Chicago where
the governor of Texas Greg Abbott is
busting illegals on a daily basis and
now these people want to boohoo on and
cry talking about how bad it is to have
illegal immigrants in their
neighborhoods in their cities when they
spent so much time telling people with
common sense that oh illegals don't take
up resources they don't bring Crime they
don't do drugs they don't do this they
don't do that you're just racist you're
just a xenophobe you hate Mexicans and
it's like no this is the reality of
bringing people here from third world
countries where you don't know who they
are you don't know where they came from
you don't know anything about them and
you bring them into your country yeah I
mean this is this is what you have to
deal with but liberals again they they
don't actually acknowledge reality until
it hits them in the face and that's just
kind of how it how it goes yeah well you
know what's funny I used to be very
pro-immigration like when I was younger
because my dad he has a software company
and he like immigrated people from India
which it was legal immigration not
illegal but until I came to England and
I just see the mass immigration they
have here where it's like it's it's it's
so bad because I live on the east and
it's just it's so dirty it's so like
it's literally disgusting because no
because they're overwritten like all the
systems are just overridden because they
have so many immigrants here yeah no I
um I definitely think that there's a
movement politically in in the west uh
specifically in Europe and in the United
States where people are pushing back you
know and they're saying look we can't
take this Mass immigration to our
countries anymore because it's it's
destroyed our society it's destroying
our culture and I actually agree with
them right I don't think that we should
just be welcoming all these people into
our country and changing our society and
our culture we we got to protect
ourselves and we gotta look out for
ourselves first so I don't blame anybody
who wants to be tough on on uh
immigration specifically illegal
immigration definitely but I am you know
I'm generally pro-legal immigration I I
just think it should be merit-based I
think that we should be yeah uh bringing
people here based off needs right if we
need a certain group of workers and we
don't have them here okay we can we can
import them or whatever but as far as
illegal immigration goes uh we need to
uh we definitely got to stem that that
is it's going out of control here in the
United States for sure so what do you
see
um as the biggest problems with the
culture today I think that the biggest
problems with the culture specifically
American cultures that I think we've
lost sight of what this country was
originally founded on right in terms of
like the basic core values Faith Freedom
heart work family I don't think that we
value those things anymore okay I think
that uh we're now pushing a culture of
uh victimhood of not having to work hard
that you're owed something for nothing
that you know you don't need to uh shoot
for excellence okay being mediocre is is
good
um you know we don't require people to
take personal responsibility and
accountability for their actions
um I think that we're just not the same
country that we used to be in regards to
what we value and what we appreciate in
fact all those things are being they're
being characterized as negative right
like you know for example if you are a
black person and you show up to work on
time right and you work hard okay you're
smart then they accuse you of you know
being a a a a white person right you're
acting white you're not really black
okay
um and this is these are real things and
they're basically trying to push the
worst behaviors on society and I think
that that's part of the the problem is
that we really don't value the things
that we used to Value why do you think
we have young people coming out like
hating America have you seen that like
the young people that what will come out
and say they hate the US well Jessica's
that's what that's what they're taught
in school right even in public school
especially in college you learn more
about history but people got to
understand that history is nuanced
nothing is black and white like for
example when we talk about slavery right
and this is right up your alley since
you have controversial opinions
so it seems right like I'm talking about
it but this is what it but this is what
it is right like people when you learn
about slavery the way they kind of teach
it the way that people kind of
understand it is that well the white man
went to Africa and then they he he stole
all the the slaves the black people and
then they bought them back to the
Americas right but they leave out the
part where you had the Africans
themselves who were fighting each other
killing each other enslaving other
Africans and helping the European when
it came to slavery because they were
selling the slaves to the Europeans
which you know without Africans the
Atlantic slave trade would not have been
as robust as it was because the
Europeans simply did not have the
ability to go into Mainland Inland
Africa in order to gather up slaves like
that not in those numbers they just
didn't have the ability to right but but
since the the white man is all-powerful
according to some of these World
revolutionaries right they leave that
part out of it and just pretend that
well slavery was just the white man's
sin and that was it and then they don't
give the Europeans credit for actually
ending the Atlantic slave trade
um which you know again they definitely
deserve credit for just like they don't
give
um white people credit for fighting in
the Civil War right in order to uh free
the slaves right so you know and the
primary slay about slaves were Irish in
the 1600s but they act like they don't
count yeah they count them as indentured
service because only only if you are
black you can only be a slave if you're
a white Irish slave apparently you're
not a slave because technically you
could work your way out of it right so
they say well you're indentured servant
even though effectively most of them
died while being an indigenous servitude
yeah well and and it was like we were
they were forced out of Ireland like
they're not voluntarily I don't know
what you would call that yeah exactly so
they so it's it's and they they say well
no no they were indentured service it's
like well no effectively they were like
they there was no real difference but
they keep saying they keep saying oh no
they were addicted servants only black
people were slaves that was it
yeah sounds a little embellished to me I
don't know just no it I mean it it is I
mean that's just what it is and that's
why I don't understand like all the
pushback that you got for just simply
stating your opinion on that subject
because you didn't say anything wrong I
mean the way they tell the story they
try to embellish it in a way to try to
basically seem like well it was only the
the white man that was responsible for
slavery nobody else the Arabs didn't
participate in it white people were
never enslaved life was really hard at
that time like it was like your your job
options are pretty much like farmhand
coal miner and factory worker in the
late 1800s life was hard like the the
one thing I've noticed that like a lot
of they do this with the women's studies
stuff too is they'll rewrite history by
basically saying you can't believe the
accounts at the time you have to look at
our perspective now yeah and I just
think it's like unfortunate because I I
think they use a lot of like really like
atrocity these like as propaganda you
know yeah 100 no I I 100 agree with you
um but you know just going back to the
like the original like kind of point of
the conversation which is that
yeah there are parts of history that
they will take and then they will
essentially try to use those parts of
History to inflame people to believe
that hey you know the white man is evil
nobody else was you know trying to take
over uh other people other tribes or
other societies only the white man did
that right European colonialism was
terrible for the world when actually it
really wasn't that positive right
without European colonialism we wouldn't
have the society that we have we
wouldn't have the standard of living
that we have and uh to try to make that
seem like a negative thing just because
you know white people were more
successful at it than everybody else who
tried to conquer the world right that to
me is just kind of ridiculous so you
know when I hear
how these people try to take history and
then they try to make it seem like that
you know there's this
good and there's this evil and that you
know it wasn't really nuanced that to me
is kind of crazy but that's how they do
it you know and they do it on multiple
or multiple things right
um like for example they never really
talk about how
and the KKK didn't just Lynch black
people they also they also lynched white
people as well too who were uh fighting
for Black people's civil rights right so
if you were a white person in the South
yeah you were hunted down and lynched by
the KKK as well too if you were
supportive of civil rights but again
when you talk about the KKK they really
only talk about it in a perspective of
well it was just black people that were
lynched nobody else was lynched like and
it's like if you're gonna tell the story
tell the whole story that way when you
tell the story people understand the
nuances behind it and it's also less
divisive when you tell it that way yeah
okay when you say well you know
um it wasn't just black people that were
you know victims of the KKK that makes
it less divisive when you say well it
wasn't just the white man that was
responsible for slavery it makes it less
divisive I mean it's they tell it in a
way to make it more divisive on purpose
to try to push this victimhood narrative
on non-white people and I I just think
that that's wrong but it's done on
purpose because they want to inflame
people and they want to direct that
energy uh in a way
that benefits the progressive agenda the
Democrat Party here in the United States
more specifically well and I think it
it's like they don't want us to identify
as American yeah you know what I mean
like if we're identifying as like black
and white then it's like we're fighting
each other and we're not identifying as
American exactly like um because I think
they say in unions they they try to hire
diverse like companies so then they
don't get together and like form a union
and ask for higher pay and I feel like
they try to do that with um like voting
they keep men and women away from each
other to
um and then the races as well just so
it's like easier to control the
population through media and messaging
yeah absolutely I mean I 100 agree I
mean that's definitely done on purpose
they deaf push certain stories and
narratives to devadas like for example
when we talk about mass shootings you
know when a mass shooting happens
um if the perpetrator
is black they will not mention a race
they will never mention a race however
if the perpetrator is white then they'll
say a white Mass shooter they will be
very like headlines guy is white yeah
okay if it's a black person they won't
say that even if it's racial right
there's been uh a couple stories maybe
two and three actually
a couple of my cover uh were there was a
black person who committed a racially
motivated mass shooting okay he was one
guy was running around and he was
basically blowing white people's brains
out okay and um
they know they was racially motivated
like they noted this was a hate crop but
the mainstream liberal media ignored the
story
and the local media Outlets that talked
about the story
essentially were afraid to mention that
the guy was black
so those stories won't go viral even
though those stories are stories of hate
crimes being committed against people
people losing their lives because their
skin color however when you have a
situation like for example the
Jacksonville shooting that happened
where you have a white person who we
know is racist based off the manifesto
allegedly right what do you mean was
there was there I don't know much about
that story well I say allegedly because
I say allegedly a lot because one when
you're in the news and you're covering
what's happening you don't know what's
true was not true so I just kind of use
that as a cover word you know some
people get mad at me when I do that
because they're like oh it's not a ledge
and I'm like well I'm just saying that
to cover myself so I don't have to come
back here and say oh well blah blah blah
no it's just everything's a ledge you
just because you never know what a real
story is even the local news doesn't
know what the story is national news I'm
telling you I've done this so long that
you need to use the word land you can
talk about any of these stories but
anyways the guy allegedly was a racist
okay he probably was definitely I mean
he probably was
um but the dude went and shot three
black people okay this is a national
news story everybody's talking about it
okay
and it gets so much attention
but when the roles are reversed you
don't see the same type of attention no
you don't see the same type of narrative
being pushed and that they do that as a
way to divide the country now again if
they cover all these stories the same
that would be more unified because I
think that black people white people can
both come together and agree that racism
against anybody whether you're black or
white is wrong but we're not at that
point we're not at that point because
we're being told according to the
anti-racist of the world aka the racist
of the world the the race is left that
uh
uh only white people can be racist
nobody else can be racist okay if you're
black and you discriminate against white
person because they're white you're not
being racist
you're being anti-racist actually right
so again these people have a financial
incentive to continue to push that they
make millions and millions of dollars
okay to find racism where there really
is no racism and that will continue to
happen as long as you have this special
class of race grifters who benefit from
racial division in our country in our
society the media benefits from it the
Democrat Party benefits from it is big
money it's big big big money and as long
as there's a financial incentive to do
it
is not going to go away because
the powers that be would much rather
have us sitting around fighting each
other over our skin color and our you
know genitalia and who we like to sleep
with rather than to actually focus on
some of the real issues in this country
and what do you think are the real
issues in this country well the real
issues in my country specifically
America maybe UK has something to say
I'm American I'm from there yeah well
okay well I don't know you know I'm not
sure what yeah in America the real
issues right now we talk about inflation
right the bite Administration spent
trillions of dollars when he got into
office and shut down the economy kept
schools closed for longer they should
have paid people to stay home instead of
working and that caused massive
inflation it caused interest rates to
shoot up exponentially over a very short
period of time which is something we
haven't seen in a long time I think that
shocked the economy the supply chain in
a way that again that's the reason why
we're seeing inflation so the cost of
living has went up tremendously I mean
it's basically unaffordable uh to get a
house okay housing prices have
skyrocketed yeah they haven't come down
as a result of mortgage rates going up
okay which makes fundamentally no sense
right if mortgage rates go up that means
that the cost to borrow money to get a
house goes up which means that you
should see prices go down because there
should be less demand but that's not
what we say we're saying people don't
even want to sell their houses they
don't want to sell their houses and they
don't want to buy a house because it's
unaffordable so we're stuck in this
weird economy where rent is unaffordable
the cost of living is unaffordable
that's probably the main issue right now
and then you also have crime on top of
that in these liberal cities more
specifically uh crime is out of control
and then you also have the Border as
well too so I think that inflation uh
crime and immigration are probably the
real issues that we should be paying
attention uh to the most okay
um and
um you know our society but again it's
hard to pay attention to a lot of these
issues when we keep going back and forth
with each other about race but it's
almost like necessary when it comes to
certain issues and we're not just
talking about race when we talk about
gender or you know sexuality or whatever
it's necessary because you have these
agendas that are being pushed for
example in school when it comes to
pushing uh critical race Theory right or
pushing
um you know the lgbtq stuff in school as
well too it's like okay well damn we got
to focus on this because we can't just
let kids get indoctrinated in school
because the indoctrination is just not
about pushing them into this lifestyle
or about
trying to make them hate white people
right it's not just about that it's also
about the fact that when these kids get
indoctrinated they become liberal
Democrat Party Progressive voters and
that's why Democrats are cool with it
that's why the left is cool with it even
though they know it's wrong it's because
these kids become more liberal they
become more indoctrinated they're more
likely to vote Democrat as a result of
it so you can't ignore it right so you
got to have the conversation you got to
talk about it because if you don't then
you're essentially giving away the Next
Generation to you know become even more
woke and Progressive than they already
are so it's a very difficult problem
because you know it's like whack-a-mole
right you try to deal with one issue and
then you got another issue and it's just
that's just the reality of it I actually
don't even think it's the kids hear me
out I think it's just the women honestly
because the voice yeah I know look at
the new studies the boys are more
conservative than ever you know but the
women it's like you know trans people
that transition 80 are women yeah so
it's like they just realize that we're
like dummies and we'll just believe
anything and they just give us this
propaganda and like even like the BLM
who was in charge of it a woman woman
yeah
and I just think you know because now we
have all these single mother homes like
I think like half of kids now are born
into single mother homes like yeah in
the first three years I can't a really
high percentage are separated from their
dad that they know if they control the
women they control everything this is
why my solution to everything is getting
we're getting rid of women's vote that's
it I'm like if we just didn't vote I
just think it would be better yeah I
think that um when it comes to the
um repeal the 19 thing you know it's
something that I've I've thought about I
have uh in in some Spirit when I'm
covering some story about women uh I
definitely think that you know it might
make sense but I just think
realistically it's not gonna happen and
it's not really a winning strategy
politically to come out here and say
that oh well I think that women should
vote but you're not in politics you're
in culture I'm in politics so I
personally look at the demographics and
how women vote the only demographic
group of women that are really the
problem when it comes to their vote are
single young women okay who vote
overwhelmingly Democratic in the
midterms you saw that because they
thought they were going to lose their
imaginary right to abortion they came
out and moved to abort we just gotta
like
yeah they came out and voted 60 to 70
percent for Democrats because of that
one issue so damn the economy damn crime
damn the Border damn the fact that we
have a you know mindless idiot in the
White House like who cares about the
country going downhill right who cares
about that abortion
all the other women right all the other
demographic women
um uh if if you are married uh they
voted Republican right if they were
older they tended to vote more
Republican it was really just single
well women that's the future though the
future is you know and we're in a
post-marriage world like you know it's I
don't say this in a hat I mean I have a
smile on my face but you know I don't I
don't say this that like I'm happy about
it but you know it's like what 70 of men
aren't looking for relationships at all
you know they're predicting half of us
are going to be single and childless
half the ones that get married are
getting divorced that's three out of
four single women
so you know that that's the future a
bunch of women living together in these
like old people homes this is what we're
gonna see yeah so I think that in
regards to the voting thing I I like the
proposal that Vivid Grandma Swami put
out in regards to raising the voting age
to 25 unless you can pass a Civics test
that immigrants have to pass in order to
get their citizenship in the United
States or they do six months of military
service I actually think that that's a
better solution than taking away women's
rights to vote and the reason why is
because I think that one if people were
more educated if they actually knew
something about the country
um I think that they would be probably
less likely to vote the way that they do
the problem is that we encourage dummies
to vote right I'm not a big democracy
guy right if if anybody wants to know
how I feel about democracy you can read
how Socrates felt about democracy okay I
think that an educated voter is a good
thing voting is a skill however I don't
believe in a society where everybody
should and can vote because most people
are severely undereducated
I think women are way dumber than men
well I think I think I think oh I think
I don't believe I know the IQ test I
don't believe him yeah I was about to
break no they they fake them no they
fake them they switched it in the 80s um
no I'm serious in the 80s they switched
them they said um they made the tests
more like female focused so they added
in like questions that women would do
well on so like the writing section was
added so yeah I just don't I think they
like do all this stuff to make us think
we're smarter than we are and then like
therefore we won't want the men because
we have all these like fake jobs that
make us think we're like making more
money than we really provide value kind
of like the WNBA they all think they're
like killing it making a lot of money
it's really just coming from the men's
paychecks that's what I think which you
know that's HR Human Resources
assistants just get the jobs because
they're like pretty young teachers kind
of just ruin your kids
yeah no I mean I think that I I think
it's like I can't say it but she's
making kind of sense dude no I mean you
do make sense I think that um I I I I I
definitely agree with some of that I
think for sure women tend to be more
emotional in regards to how they think
about things and I think men tend to be
more logical and methodic in regards to
how we go how we go about thinking about
certain issues right like I think again
you know for example when we saw the
women come out and vote in droves
because they thought that their right to
abortion would be taken away uh that was
emotional right if you understand rovie
Roe v Wade being overturned did not take
away their right to or right it's not
really even right but it didn't take
away their right to abortion it just
made it a state issue okay and a lot of
these women thought oh no abortion is
about to be banned like abortion is
banned I need to go out here and vote
it's like well bush is not banned okay
um you know it's now a state issue and
if you really want an abortion if your
state ends up Banning it which most
won't okay they're not going to outright
Bannon it's just not politically
feasible uh you can just go to one of
these blue States who will allow it on
demand okay up until birth if that's
what you want right
um so again I mean I mean
when I saw that happen when I the
midterms really I think did
sour my opinion in regards to women and
voting so I will give you that right
like and I'm afraid that that's gonna
happen again in 2024 like that is my one
thing where I'm like oh it will you know
and the indictments are not stopping
Trump nothing's stopping Trump right now
it looks like he's gonna win the primary
he's just getting better and better
Biden is getting worse he's
deteriorating there's no way that this
country can come out and vote for brain
dead fool over Trump but these people
don't vote like that they don't think
that way they're gonna think with you
know their emotions and you're gonna
have a lot of women that'll come out
here and say oh well we want our right
to abortion and then they're gonna vote
for Biden simply based off that issue
and that to me is just wow I'll tell you
why I'll tell you what switched my mind
okay about women voting because I kind
of did it at first as a joke I was just
kidding and it was so funny because Abba
and preach made this video like about me
saying that I said that but it was like
a joke at first it was a joke until I
started reading the anti-suffragettes
like writings about it and they
basically said that if women get the
right to vote that taxes are going to go
up regulations are going to go up and
it's going to be the breakdown of the
family and I was like huh
that's what happened they like all the
women because it was mostly women that
were like against women voting they had
like all these groups that were like
campaigning against it and then yeah and
they also you used to be able to like
throw your husband in jail if he didn't
pay the bills but they could also put
something over your face for nagging
yeah that's funny so I was like I mean
they were kind of right you know but I
feel like they have to find a way to
limit the women vote I don't know if
it's through net taxpayers something
like that landowners because we just
spend a bunch of money you know yeah and
we like don't save and then so I'm like
if you just did net taxpayers we do
we're not tax loss so I would just give
her to yeah I mean I I definitely hear
you I I I think how do the politicians
say it when they agree with something
but they don't want to really say they
agree with it I agree with the spirit of
what you're saying
I agree with the spirit of it I just
don't think that um you know repealing
women's right to vote is really the way
to go if you want to wait because you
have to you actually have to win if you
want to do that and you're not going to
win campaigning or take away their vote
so I'm just saying I I'm a practical guy
so that's the way I kind of that's the
way I'm looking at but what you're
saying is correct in regards to how the
government
um will Target women right for example
Lyndon B Johnson the Great Society
and the expansion of welfare right
essentially incentivizing women to marry
the government right they don't need
their man okay if you have kids out of
wedlock hey you're going to get all this
these government benefits and again that
is incentivized women to vote in a way
in which they're like oh well you know
the government's taking care of me let
me vote for the party uh that is going
to continue to give me more hands out
handouts handouts for just being a woman
and not actually hold me accountable for
the actions that you know I participate
in like you know for example having kids
out of wedlock right I mean there is no
real penalty for having kids out of
wedlock because you get rewarded for it
right through government assistance and
um you know it's basically made it so
men are expendable to a lot of women and
that's why we see a lot of single parent
households led by uh single mothers in
which statistically speaking that leads
to more crime and more poverty and more
issues in these communities and again
these communities are being
led by women right and uh that's just
kind of how it is right when you take
the man out of the home you take the man
out of the community you know this is
the result right it's chaos and
destruction but I think a lot of it is
on purpose to a certain extent
um some of it's not some of it is kind
of well-meaning uh but they're just
naive about human nature and how things
work and how you need men you need a man
in the household you need fathers and I
think that
um that is part of I think some of the
biggest issues that we have culturally
again is the lack of fathers
um in homes okay in single mother
households I think that uh if that was
an issue that we could fix I think a lot
of other things would fix itself
including voting and crime and poverty
and you know a lot of the issues that we
deal with can just be fixed by going
back to traditionalism really I think um
I think that men should automatically
get custody like I think
that they should make policies that help
the kids and since women we just like
raise such bad kids like we're just
terrible at it no I'm serious like I
just every number will tell you that so
it's like if we're so bad at it why
don't they just give it to the men when
they raise better kids well I just I I
actually just I I well I think there is
something to be said about a woman a
woman's role right I think that you just
need both I think we need to
disincentivize
divorce we need to disincentivize that
would be a great disincentive if you
leave because women are the ones leaving
we know this so it's like yeah so if we
if we
hey lady if you leave he gets the kids
not you
I think some women would probably leave
anyways you know what that's that's fine
right it is what it is
um I just think we need to take away I
just think we need no she has to pay
child support yeah I think we need I
think we need to cut the social safety
net yeah that's what I really believe I
think we need to take away we need to
punish women we need to make their lives
harder for women that have kids out of
wedlock just make their lives as hard as
possible so that they're like I need to
make sure that hey you know whoever I
decide to sleep with and have a kid with
that this is who I actually want to be
with and I'm not just going to leave
them for petty reasons like oh I'm not
100 happy which you know I mean you know
you're an expert in that you know why
women leave these marriages no reason no
he was he was holding her back that's
when I get a lot oh really yeah I mean
what does that mean
I wanted okay I'll translate it's
basically I really I watch some stuff on
social media and it convinced me that I
was just an amazing entrepreneur and my
husband said hey watch the kids and I
just thought no you're holding me back
and therefore I can out earn you some do
it most just kind of live and dilute
even if they do do it they just spend
all the money anyway and then just yeah
one time one time I'll tell you a story
one time this chick came on the show
and I I remember I asked her on the show
um if the guy was like a good dad so I
was like why'd you leave you know and
then
um she was like yeah he was a good dad
great whatever a couple months later
she's like crying to me trying to get me
to take the stream down
but I'm too smart I know what she's
trying to do because that's like you
know what I mean because he can just
take the stream and show that to a judge
but it's like later they'll go to court
and like cry that he was like the worst
thing ever so they get money basically
yeah I think when it comes to the
relationships and I will say this is my
criticism of the red appeal to a certain
extent is that even as a more
traditional and conservative like man I
I definitely think that relationships
are a partnership I think they are
transactional but they're also a
partnership in the sense that
I think both parties got to understand
that hey I need to make sure I'm always
bringing value and things to the table
so that my partner is satisfied and I
think well a lot of relationships break
down is when one or both parties forget
that aspect of a relationship is that
you're supposed to be bringing things to
the table and that there's supposed to
be in equilibrium in which both Partners
feel like they're getting something out
of it and that they are progressing in
some way I think that some women
right may have some legitimate gripes
when it comes to their issues and
relationships if for example uh a man
isn't paying all the bills or footing
most of the bills financially but yet
he's expecting her to work and cook and
clean and do all this stuff around the
house I'm not necessarily sure how
that's fair to a woman and I could
definitely see why a woman would feel
like okay this is not fair for me
um and I think that there's some aspects
that are kind of being looked over which
I think men could do a better job of
basically
incentivizing women to stay in
relationships with them it clearly
there's not balance in that relationship
so I I I I do kind of think there's
uh more blame being put on women then
there should be even though I do think
women should get a majority of the blame
I I do think that there's some
situations where I'm starting to see
like
some things where I'm like uh I'm not
necessarily sure about that like I was
watching the um do whatever podcast
and I think the dude said I might be
miscored I'm not sure I should have
somewhat said it
um he's like I don't I don't pay for
First Dates
and I'm like I understand why you don't
want to do that because you don't want
to find a girl that's a gold digger or
whatever but if you don't pay for the
first date then you're automatically
going to be eliminated as a possible
companion because that is what men are
expected to do I don't think that the
solution for women not appreciating
traditional men is for men to all of a
sudden now be less traditional I think
that they should be more traditional but
also be more selective about who they
decide to be with and to make sure that
they are appreciating them as a
traditional man that's just my opinion
yeah well I just think his his point of
view is more why would you give a
traditional outcome when women aren't
traditional it's like what four percent
of women are virgins on their wedding
days that's a traditional you don't have
like that's we I think we get married
around 31 years old you know I mean so
it's like I I don't really see a problem
with like I mean I do think a lot of
women will reject you on that so you
know do yeah but like I kind of
understand where he's coming from where
he's like why would I pay for a chick
that's not traditional like why would
she get a traditional outcome yeah but
why go on a date with a woman that you
didn't think was traditional in the
first place well there's they don't they
don't exist I don't I don't I think a
lot of women kind of Rebrand themselves
and like try to pretend but it's like
we've really had um because again if we
go back to because the problem is this
is what chicks do when they want to like
confuse everybody they won't give an
actual definition like what is
traditional right so I I want to say
let's let's go to the Bare Bones
definition a traditional chick is a
woman that's a virgin on her wedding day
that that's Bare Bones traditionalism
right she gets married before 25 not
saying it's me right I'm just saying
they're not they don't really exist yeah
you get a lot of pushback for that
though you get a lot of pushback for
pushing the whole you know man to Mary
Burgess thing but you know yeah well I I
think that the problem is that you know
what What is marriage marriage is
supposed to be between two virgin so I'm
not saying they'll never marry a
non-virgin but I think the fact that
like quote unquote Trad cons don't push
it at all it's like you're kind of
setting a lot of guys up for failure
because I know guys that are like in the
church they're very traditional and
conservative the problem is there's no
young women that want to get married
that are actually virgin well I think
personally that there are women out
there like that I just don't know if
some of these guys that say they want
that actually really want that like for
example I did I just did a recent video
in which I was critical of the fact that
I think a lot of these podcasts they're
bringing on only fans girls and it's
like these only fans girls don't have a
clue about how relationships work
because they're sex workers right
prostitutes cannot understand how a
relationship is supposed to function
because their relationships are 100
financially transactional okay they're
doing something in my opinion and I
think it's unnatural towards women so
it's like why keep bringing on these
women who are the furthest thing away
from being traditional so I'll tell you
I'll tell you why as being someone that
gets accused of this a lot yeah oh no we
don't it's it's an epidemic like you
think we can you know how hard it is to
get women to show up on a date yeah you
know it's like you think we can recruit
that easily for
so I'm saying like I've had over 600
chicks logged here right now there's
more recorded only fans workers than
teachers like that's how big of a
demographic that is this is the new
generation we're in a post-marriage
society and I feel like a lot of times
like tradcons are like oh just go back
to traditionalism I say I think it
sounds nice that's an easy salad just
say good luck like I've had 600 plus
women I've logged all of them I've you
know I'm in Europe so I've had Americans
on the show I've had Eastern like more
traditional countries social media is
ruining everyone like especially women
like because you just get in our ear We
Believe damn near anything even the more
like mild ones they'll still repeat back
to me like feminist talking points um
you look at the birth rates in even more
traditional countries they're all
dropping and and that kind of says women
are more modern because again less kids
yeah no I I think yeah for sure I
definitely agree with you in the sense
that I can see why you have a hard time
like finding actual traditional women to
come on to show because traditional
women probably aren't going to want to
come on these shows and be associated
with you know whatever oh oh no I talked
to oh trust me I've been to Northern
Wisconsin I've been I'll tell you what
the problem is in the 1900s they put a
lot of these propaganda devices and all
the big institutions so I'm talking
about the Christian Church the Catholic
why do you think they had all those gay
people in the cat I'm Catholic why do
you think they had on like that huge
Scandal because like the big family sent
a lot of these guys into the seminaries
to basically like rewrite the Bible
essentially like you hear the like
Mutual submission all that nonsense from
the Christian church so like essentially
I even I went to like Northern Wisconsin
this was just for research purposes
because I always get this from got like
this is my big criticism they won't want
to come on the show didn't record them
just went to talk to them whatever and I
found I found the more traditional women
and I talked to their husbands right
their biggest complaint the church makes
them feminists the church makes that
yeah yeah like and I'm telling you these
are these are the men that married The
Virgins these are the men that they
learn their living and if if this is the
feedback I'm getting from like the most
traditional places I think it's kind of
a cope when it's like oh it's just the
women on the pot no this is brainwashing
across the board well put it this way I
think I'll say this I think the women
that you guys bring on a podcast are
more extreme but I do think that your
point is is correct in the sense that
yeah
um especially this happens in the black
church right I mean this is it's it's oh
yeah all about catering to the black
woman in the black church right because
again they're the most emotional so you
know you got black women preachers you
know you're not supposed to right like
you got all types of stuff that you're
really not supposed to have going on in
church and what they're pushing in the
church but they're pushing it because
again that is what women want to hear
and women are you know some of the
biggest kind of you know supporters of
that and it's hard to get women to
support something like that when you're
actually really pushing some of the more
traditional aspects of it because
in a sense women you know kind of don't
want to be traditional right they want
to be told you know they want to be
empowered they you know want power and
um I I definitely I think that there's
some some truth to what you're saying
about even more traditional women still
are being you know kind of well okay if
you had three generations of plumbers
right if you had three generations of
plumbers that looked like plumbers acted
like plumbers they were dressed like
plumbers but weren't actually plumbers
right you would kind of lose the
knowledge by the third generation and
what happened is it's like the 60 to 80
year olds like they were the first wave
of like propaganda
um yeah and I've interviewed women
around the age of 85 and they're they
said in the 60s 70s that feminism was
even stronger than it is today and back
then there was no alternative media so
just imagine this is down their throats
24 7 TV on whatever so that like that
first generation of women told their
daughters to go to college focus on them
themselves they they didn't teach their
daughters how to do traditional stuff
that's where you get the microwave
dinners the moms like you know then
social media comes in with the next and
the 40s to 60 year olds I call the
generation of like shitty wives because
they looked like wives acted like wives
but half of them divorced their husbands
the 60 to 80 year old separated a lot
but they didn't divorce 40 to 60 year
olds now it's fine to get divorced you
can divorce your husband none of them
believe in submission ask any 40 to 60
year old chick it's very rare they
believe in obeying you know
um and then
um the Next Generation which is my
generation I call the ones we just don't
get down the aisle because it's like we
have two generations of women the first
generation maybe had skills of a wife
like traditional more but they didn't
have the mentality and they told their
daughters to not trust their husbands
etc etc and I've just interviewed so
many families about this where I go
through each generation it's all the
same more or less right and this is this
same in
third like more third world countries
like I've interviewed Nigerian families
I've interviewed like Eastern European
it's all the it's all the same and so
now
um really you have three generations of
women that look some were wives maybe
got the ring but didn't
really believe in the true definition of
a wife which is like submission like a
helpmate right again I I think that you
know as society as we become more modern
and we've empowered women I just think
personally the key as a more traditional
man to finding something that you can
get as close as possible to a
traditional woman is basically making
sure that you're bringing as much as you
can to the table so that you're not
asking too much from a woman
um and then also trying to make sure
that you know the woman actually does
appreciate what you bring to the table
as a man and is willing to reciprocate
that through you know a level of
submission that is acceptable for you as
a man but also having to understand that
because we live in a modern society that
you know they're going to be some things
that you really just can't change and
you can't control and you it might not
be
very wise if you actually do want to end
up getting married if you actually do
want a family to get hung up on certain
things like whether or not a woman is a
virgin which again most women you know
hey an ideal Society yeah I mean 85 85 a
year ago 85 or not a year ago 100 years
ago 85 percent of women were yeah
exactly and I'm I'm hey I wish it was
like that too virgins I think you know
ideally that that's what you want as a
man that's nothing's more traditional
than that but you got to understand okay
this is the current modern day that we
live in we need to kind of update the
way that we thinking in our in our
standards to something that's reasonable
and practical therefore we can actually
maximize our own happiness in life and I
think that having discernment as a man
um I think is is important but also I
think what you're saying definitely is
resonating with a lot of men and I think
that's the reason why a lot of these
young men in the red pill for example
somebody like snico converted to Islam
right I and I think that because Islam
did not push that one I was like what
I'm going well I'm gonna push it because
that's why I'm observing I also think
that's why Tate is getting some of the
hate that he's getting yeah from
traditional conservatives is because
he's basically pushing Islam on young
men yeah and Islam basically is the
answer to what you're saying right if
you really want something traditional
you want a woman to submit to you not
work cook clean raise kids have no
questions
used to do it you used to what you used
to have traditional Christian women yeah
you used to but yeah what I'm saying in
today's society because Christianity has
become so Progressive and we don't live
in a state we don't actually live in a
country that has like Christianity
culturally we're Christian but from a
government perspective we're secular so
Islam is not just a religion is also
just a way of life it's government it's
like Saudi Arabia is a religious state
so when you have the government pushing
that top down everybody in society is
going for it yeah that works okay and I
think a lot of these men and the things
that you're you're saying that is I
think is pushing people towards Islam
and I think that's part of the reason
why you know some people like Andrew
Tate are getting a lot of backlash it's
not then it's just also the trafficking
thing too but that trafficking stuff
those allegations that has been out
there for a while I think that you just
started to see some of these traditional
conservative uh guys kind of really go
out to tape because of what we see in
regards to the influence of Islam
popping up because that to me in regards
to what the red pill is it seems like
what they're wanting they're they're
essentially wanting something that's
Uber traditional which is Islam right
that's what it is no I mean there's some
there's some Catholics in the red pill
but yeah I mean well that's what I'm
saying but you have the cat like you
have Catholics yeah again they're the
ones that they have an issue with I mean
even cap like even modern day uh
Catholicism they're more Progressive
they're still more on average they're
still more Progressive than somebody
that's a Muslim that's true and I I
really do think that some of the
backlash that Tate is getting is because
like he is pushing people towards Islam
because the red pill seems to be pushing
people that way I mean that that's where
it's that's the only Society where it's
like like it's normal normal and totally
acceptable nobody will call you a
misogynist for having these type of
traditional expectations right well
because even in the church you get
called a misogynist for like this type
of stuff I see what you're saying
exactly it's cute it's Christianity has
become too Uber Progressive and because
we don't have a state that actually
enforces the Bible right uh like Saudi
Arabia will enforce the Quran
do you think we should uh that's America
was founded on not having that right we
were running away from that right or
from a religious state from a king from
a monarchy so I I don't necessarily
think that that's a good idea because I
think that that would actually go
against freedom of religion and it would
actually make it harder to practice
Christianity because if you were to make
the United States officially a Christian
State then you have to figure out is it
Catholic is it Baptist is it Methodist
right is it this is it that and once you
start to get into that conversation that
I think that makes freedom of religion
less less prevalent in this country
um which that's probably an argument
that won't be popular in conservative
circles but I actually believe that
to preserve freedom of religion you need
a state that is not officially religious
because that allows everybody literally
to practice their own religion if you
made a United States officially a
Christian like State
um you would have to decide what type of
Christian state it is that it is and
that would lead to a whole lot of issues
and problems that we were running away
from originally yeah
sometimes I wonder if it would help I'm
not like as political so I don't I don't
know all the like different types of
governments or whatever but sometimes I
wonder if it was better if it would be
better because I don't know like
sometimes I just think it's like kind of
sad how Godless the US is now like the
gay flags and all that stuff like or
even in London like they had a whole
street full of the gay stuff and I'm
like if it was a Christian or like
Catholic or something this wouldn't fly
you know but it seems like when you
don't have that like it kind of lets
crazy people take over at times well I
mean you know I I think that throughout
history Society has never become less
Progressive right we've always
progressed but I think the problem with
modern day progressivism is that it
actually is leading to regressivism uh
especially on certain issues like race
like for example the race Hustlers are
trying to push segregation when we're
supposed to be progressing past you know
segregation and racist ISM but they want
to take us back right so I think that it
in general it's hard to stop progress I
guess it's just about which progress it
makes more sense and which progress
doesn't make more make sense when you
talk about the issue of Pride and lgbtq
I think people will argue that hey you
know if you take religion out of
marriage which you know for a lot of
people is impossible but if it's just a
government thing then you know hey maybe
gay people get married is not
necessarily into the world right if you
take religion out of as long as you're
not forcing churches to uh acknowledge
or anything like that or pushing on any
type of religious institution if it's
something that the government
acknowledges simply for tax benefits
hey maybe it's something that is I want
to ban that yeah and then but what I'm
saying is that the country got on board
with that thinking that that was it
right
lgbtq people you got all your rights
right there are no more rights that you
need however the problem is that because
you have
people who don't believe that enough
progress is enough now all of a sudden
lgbtq rights is not just that it's now
oh well the right for kids to talk to
their teachers about sex in school the
right for kids to be able to cut off
their genitalia all types of crazy stuff
that really has nothing to do with
somebody's fundamental rights as much as
it has to do with progressing an agenda
um and um I think as men this country
was mainly built by men I think that
we've been to pillars of society and men
were the ones that you know gave women
the right to vote men were the ones that
have led some of these these kind of
movements to do I guess what you would
call the right thing but we also at the
same time are the ones that kind of let
it get out of control right and uh I
think it's up to men to put the genie
back in the bottle yeah I go back and
forth and if you can go back or not I
kind of because part of me is I'm like I
just want to ban birth control abortion
and I want to ban the gay marriage like
I would just ban it all but I'm like I
don't know if that would work or not in
Pearl's world I mean well I mean again
if you I mean you know I'm just saying
out there in the Middle East that sounds
great and I don't think anybody would do
oh I don't think it's the same as the
Middle East I'm like okay 150 years ago
all these things were banned it was not
the Middle East yeah yeah but but what
I'm telling you is that the difference
between Islam modern day Islam is that
modern day Islam it is progressing like
for example they may have some women
that can now Drive in Saudi Arabia or
whatever but it ain't it's at a snail's
place you know it's like it's like a
snail speed Christianity on the hand has
progressed off a cliff right to the
point where you could argue that modern
day Christianity is not really even West
in the Bible right you could argue that
so I'm just saying like that's where
we're at in the sense that you know I
mean I think that we've gotten too
Progressive when it comes to religion to
the point where it really doesn't it
doesn't mean much of anything anymore
and I do think that that is the
difference between 150 years ago and now
is that back doing 150 years ago people
were actually following things in the
Bible like you didn't have women
preachers and teachers and stuff like
that it was all men right this is what I
say yes yeah I mean I'm just saying so
it's like but now because you know we're
not as religious as we used to be or we
don't practice it the way that we used
to practice it in the sense of actually
following what's in their book I think
that's why you see a lot of this stuff
kind of is like okay well you know
whatever right we're
we're Society built off Freedom you know
so you know it's it is what it is you
know I mean it's it's one of those
things that I think is uh it's a very
complex kind of problem I don't have a
solution really I got some ideas I don't
know if they'd work or not but I got
plenty of ideas yeah I'm serious so you
said border crime and inflation are the
three issues that we should be focused
on right now with all of this home as
well too father fatherlessness homes
yeah and fatherless okay so I wanna I'm
curious if you agree I would ban child
support I would ban alimony and I would
ban divorce
and I would just say ladies ladies
ladies
just stay with him and you have no
problems
so here's the thing I think that we
should disincentivize divorce okay I
think that we should make alimony more
Equitable in regards to you know
uh men not necessarily having to Bear
the financial burden of a divorce and I
think with child support I think that at
the very least you should have a DNA
test and a very low that's
like the one thing I'm like yeah you
need a deal and before a woman can get
child support from a man that undef like
it has to be like she has to be able to
prove that he's the father right because
some of these women they don't know who
their father is so they just guessed
right and um you know some men don't
fight it some men just say whatever okay
whatever but um I think that if you
actually had to make women prove I think
that that would definitely disincent
about some of these women who just sleep
with a whole bunch of men they don't
even know who the father of their kid is
right like that would kind of suck if
you couldn't get paid unless you get
approved with DNA evidence that that was
the father
I don't even think they should be able
to get paid regardless because in my
opinion it's like okay birth control's
legal I mean like so so is
abortion you know what I mean it's like
you don't get both you you get all this
Choice with your reproduction okay
if it doesn't work out that was like 10
year choices you know I'm like this is
just on you Lady again I'm I'm with you
in a sense that I agree with the spirit
of distance women financially from
divorce and from having kids out of
wedlock I definitely agree with that I
think that a lot of it in my opinion is
just you know getting rid of some of
these social safety nets that we have
built in place for women but then also
some of it is as well too is making kind
of the process of a divorce more fair
towards men and child support be more
fair towards men and maybe just maybe if
you take away some of these incentives
people will be incentivized to actually
work out their differences in their
relationship rather than to just break
it off into end it I don't know so I
sometimes question are you what do you
think of patriarchy you think it's a
good thing or a bad thing well I think
it's great yeah I think there's like a
natural order in the world right and I
just think it's supposed to go God men
women children
and I think sometimes it's kind of like
the question is we used to have a
patriarchy I would argue we have a
matriarchy now and it's like going
forward do we make things more equal so
equal would be basically making child
support laws more fair like if she makes
more than she gets money you know more
like what you were saying which is more
egalitarian or do we make it more
patriarchal
and my feeling is we make it more
patriarchal but I'm a woman I got my
feelings you know so it's like I don't
know but but
um it's interesting because sometimes I
wonder why more of the conservatives
like argue for egalitarianism over like
patriarchy well that's because you have
okay so for example when we talk about
like the divorce stuff yeah and like in
child support from a conservative
perspective and this is I think why you
have a lot of these conservative
politicians that push this stuff and Ray
appeal to conservative is kind of
different and and this is where it kind
of divorces even though there's a lot of
overlap yeah is that from a conservative
perspective right from a man is supposed
to provide perspective that's why things
are
basically shifted against men in the uh
divorce courts because the idea is that
from a traditional perspective a man is
supposed to be the provider he's
expected to provide and to take care of
the children and in the case of a
separation it's on the onus is on demand
from a traditional perspective
um if the the the the you know they
can't work their relationship out but I
guess also from a traditional
perspective there's not supposed to be
any divorce in the first place so I
guess you can make the argument both
ways but I think that the way things are
um in regards to things financially
being not in men's favor is because from
a conservative perspective from a
traditional perspective men are supposed
to be the providers and and therefore
you know that's why the onus is always
put on demand financially when it comes
to these situations yeah well I mean
they are still I think it's actually
kind of because if you look at female
Breadwinners it's like seven thirteen
percent maybe and even if you look at 50
50 most of the time the men still
provide more and they work so they might
work like 20 years longer than the women
yeah it's like the women will retire at
like 60 the men's 75 I don't know the
exact numbers so but it's almost like we
just get all this Freedom with none of
the like responsibility that comes with
it you know yeah again I don't think
that we've updated our conservative
thinking to
the modern day yeah and this is why I
say like in regards to where I'm at in
regards to track Converses red pill I'm
in the middle right like I I see the
traditional conservative argument I
understand the marriage behind that and
I see the red pill argument I understand
marriage behind that I'm literally in
the middle um I think that the red pill
has gotten a little bit too extreme on
the dating stuff uh and blaming
everything on women's stuff and I think
that oh I think everything's women's
fault so yeah I think that's a little
bit extreme but that's and liberal and
Elite liberal men I'll give it to Elite
liberal men well I I 100 agree with you
on that uh Elite liberal men are
definitely the biggest issue right
um but when it comes women I mean they
didn't have to take the money to leave
but who enabled these women you know
what's so funny it's like but yeah but
they didn't have to take it it's like
okay if you give me a hundred dollars to
shoot my brother is it your fault for
giving me a hundred dollars or my fault
for shooting him
brother is is the proper well I mean it
ruins Society right that I would say
it's it's even worse because if I can't
really look at it they look at it they
look at it as well you're empowering me
you're allowing me to make my own income
and to do this and do that and be the
boss and be the CEO look here's the
thing I don't think that women should
necessarily not have those opportunities
uh I just think that if that's what
we're gonna do then we have to have some
balance and I think that we're out of
balance as society and that's the
problem I think that traditional
conservatives don't realize that we're
out of balance and they haven't updated
there yeah they're still in like 1950s
exactly like we don't live in the 1950s
but that's what I'm saying when it comes
to the mindset and that's what I was
telling you you know why the courts are
the way they are the traditional process
behind it thinking okay the man's the
provider he needs to be the one paying
child support whatever yeah that works
in the 40s and 50s when women don't have
a job
right like when women don't work where
it's like that's not really a thing like
that that would make sense but now in
today's society where you have women
that you know hey they boss babes right
they're out here doing this doing that
getting their money maybe we should
equalize things a little bit make things
a little bit more fair for both parties
and I think that that's I think they're
kind of the real issue with traditional
conservative thinking in regards to
relationships and dating and you know
the judicial system and all this other
stuff it's just simply that we haven't
updated our thinking to modern society
and we're not giving a conservative
solution to Modern issues we're giving a
conservative solution to issues that are
not like that does not grounded in what
we're dealing with today in regards to
modern society and I think that's why so
many people
are more attracted to somebody like
Andrew Tate more so than somebody like a
Ben Shapiro and talk about young men
right and I think that's something that
has been a debate right conservative
versus red pill it's like well why does
Andrew Tate have all these young men
young boys following him is because Tate
has put a a an actual modern update on
some of these issues right but he's
still coming at it from a somewhat
conservative perspective and I really do
think that a lot of these traditional
conservative like influencers see that
as a threat oh yeah that is why they go
out to take so hard and that's why you
get so many so much criticisms uh of
taking red pill from traditional
conservatives it's been because Tate has
actually done something that a lot of
these guys have failed to do which is to
be a role model for young men that young
men want to follow Tate's following or
not
40 56 year old man like you know a
traditional conservative man's following
would be no Tate has the the young the
young guys and I think that's what a lot
of the traditional conservative men want
they want to affect young men but
they're not presenting
an attractive
kind of lifestyle and solution for young
men and I think that's where traditional
conservatives are losing some of these
men even though they may say hey I'm
more conservative right they might say
that in a survey but are they voting
that way
are they actually doing things in a way
that will have an effect on society the
same way that women are these women that
are overwhelmingly liberal they vote
they go out and they vote for these
liberal policies like abortion why don't
we have young men who are just as
passionate about you know
acting in their own best interest the
same way that we have young women that
are is interested in acting you know in
their own best interests just because
you have
these Progressive women influencers
right who actually are political they're
saying hey look we're political right
I'm caught up with the culture okay this
is what we're pushing on women this is
you know empowerment whatever right
but the problem is is that on the right
side of the aisle Andrew Tate
is not
overtly political so he's not telling
any of these young guys to go out and
vote Republican or vote conservative he
doesn't even claim to be conservative
right on the right we don't we don't
have the same type of I would say
political influence over man Even though
they are more
um I guess susceptible to our messaging
we have it bridged the political aspect
and cultural aspect of it in a way that
is done on the left and I think that's
why
we're in a situation that we're in in
regards to how you can have such a young
group of women like a single demographic
literally affect the whole outcome of
election is because they are culturally
and politically on the same page and I'm
not necessarily sure if that's the same
for uh young men
yeah well I mean I think they like Tate
because he's like cool he's got the cars
he's got the castle and the Trad cons
will come in and be like well that's
that's materialistic I'm like men like
the cars they like the hot women you
know what I'm like you know that's what
I'm saying yeah and then they also kind
of like put us chicks on this crazy
pedestal it's just like do all this
stuff for the women I'm like what the
why I mean honestly I'm not even trying
to be rude I just look at the numbers
I'm like like from a historical point of
view 85 90 of us would have been like
thrown out two they're like two kids
what are these chicks doing and like
they're like maybe two not even two like
you know yeah and I don't I don't say
this in a happy way I just look at the
numbers from 200 years ago to now I'm
like wow in terms of a value proposition
we're not really so why are they putting
us on this like crazy pedestal you need
to be so amazing for a wife and kids
it's like yeah I like it sounds good but
we're just in a in a post-marriage
society I don't I don't say this in a
happy way but you know to think about
this think about this this is why I harp
on the Virgin thing okay we look at body
count stats okay virgin 80 chance of a
happy marriage
um you've slept with five men it goes
down to twenty percent the perception of
men right you know I've talked to all
these guys is that most women are over
five right that's the perception okay
even at three it's like thirty percent
so that's like a thirty percent
chance or a seventy to eighty percent
chance of failure
from female promiscuity that with a
system that'll take everything away from
you
you know so it's like that's why I say
the Virgin thing I'm like the only
solution from a stats point of view I
can think of is to Marry The Virgins and
I had this thought after a show because
again I've interviewed so many hundreds
of women and I just like was
interviewing like these women from the
ages of like 18 to like 40 and I just
found the older women were just way
worse in my generation 25 to 45 I'm like
terrible so I'm like I'm like if I was a
guy I would just go as young as I
possibly could that's what I would do
yeah I mean I think I think generally
speaking that you know I mean as a man I
think that's the most desirable right is
little body count as possible and
younger but I I think that you know I
mean and my thoughts sorry I got one
more thing women we just do whatever's
cool do you know how many women have
mentioned Kim Kardashian to me on my
show like I can't even like put this
into words how sick I'm hearing up this
woman but Kim Kardashian sells a dream
right she's pretty hot she's in her 40s
she's gotten not one not two but three
high value men to marry her you know I
mean she only gets these I mean she
divorced like it's gonna end in Failure
right but like as women we just see
what's happening now so it's like this
is like selling a dream to us chicks and
I was like if all the top man I'm not
even saying every guy would have to do
it but if the top 10 percent of men got
together and said we're not getting
married until we get a virgin I'm like I
bet you the next generation of women
might they kind of do what's cool
yeah I mean well I maybe I mean I I
would hope that that would be the result
okay but
um you know me personally I like to
think about this issue the same way I
think about the race issue I think the
way that we're playing up the divide in
the issue is probably
more exaggerated and hyperbolic than the
actual situation in reality now don't
get me wrong I understand divorce rates
you know that you know most likely
you're going to get divorced I get it
like it's an issue but um I do believe
in a possibility of getting a
relationship with a woman and her not
being perfect but being good enough
right or you know good enough to make a
relationship work in both both parties
really want to make it work and I think
the beauty of the red pill is not in the
dating stuff I think is actually really
in the self-improvement I think it's
when you talk about Fitness you know
business networking Finance whatever
right helping a man be about a man and
be the best version of himself I think
is going to be the best thing that he
can do to find a woman that he's going
to be satisfied with and and I agree
with you and this all like sounds nice
right and it's such a I wish I could
sell that but I just can't because I
look at the numbers right and it's 75
plus will not have Happy Endings the
majority of Our Generation it's not
going to be good and I don't see this in
a happy way I mean I do I mean I've kind
of numb to it now but it's like it's
like it's like that's not you know it's
not true most people aren't gonna have a
stable family structure in our
generation yeah I hope it switches but I
just don't I don't see it switching
until they really switch the systems
because for whatever reason when women
get leverage like think about the last
hundred years the policies women have
passed because all the politicians are
catering to the women
um so it's like terrible divorce laws
um I mean what we keep seeing these guys
getting locked up for crimes they didn't
do yeah
um child support like all of these laws
women have passed have been pretty bad
so I'm like I just do I see it getting
better I wish I did I just you know
don't well I definitely don't think it's
going to get better if we keep kind of
you know pushing men and women apart you
know by you know telling men hey you
know you should just not you know don't
worry about women yeah I actually agree
with that when you're in your 20s right
as a man like yeah focus on yourself
like do what you can do to become the
best man that you can be and then to
that point I think you will as a man
probably have more options to choose
from and increase your chances of
success I'm a practical person I'm
looking at it from what would I tell the
average man or the average young man
that's disaffected I'm not gonna tell
him you know just say screw women screw
family right don't don't I wouldn't stop
that because all these all these these
statistics about divorce and I want this
other stuff I wouldn't say it either I
just think it's gonna happen like I mean
it's already happening you know you're
right you're right statistically
speaking but if you act but if you at an
individual level if I if I was to say
well what do you do about that as an
individual right I would say as a man
just worry about becoming the best
version of yourself that way you have
more options and you don't have to
necessarily settle for something that is
not gonna be a good situation I think
there are a lot of good women out there
I just think that you know you can't
have the mindset of where all women are
terrible
if you're trying to find a good woman
okay you gotta be open-minded too okay
the girl is not gonna she's not she
might not be a virgin but you know what
you know she's she's trying right she's
trying to be you know more traditional
she respects me as a man she caters to
me okay she does all the things that
she's that she's supposed to do as a
woman and she makes me happy just
because she doesn't have all these
things that doesn't necessarily mean
that a relationship can't work I think
that the more of a man improves himself
that's the more leverage he's gonna have
over oh a woman and it's probably gonna
make it more likely that he's gonna have
a successful relationship the more
leverage that he has because what you're
talking about in regards to what has
happened over time only thing you're
saying is that will men have less
leverage because of laws that's it they
do so I could argue that well
relationships worked out in the past not
because everybody was happy with them
but because men just simply had the
leverage so I think that in well yeah I
think anybody I think he will leverage I
think evil happens when women start to
get leverage typically I think that's
like Adam and Eve and the women got the
Apple never happy yeah but I don't I
don't want you to misconstrue I'm not
saying like women are evil yeah but I'm
more saying like I think you're gonna
keep seeing men walking away and tell
you the system switch and I don't blame
a man for walking away yeah and like I
don't blame any man but walking away in
his 20s I think men should walk away in
their 20s I think in your 20s you need
to be focused on I've got a career you
need to be focused on being healthy fit
business getting as much leverage as you
can so when you actually are ready to be
in a relationship now you have a certain
degree of Leverage where it's going to
make it a lot harder for a woman to not
submit to you because you're a man that
has shown that hey I'm worth submitting
to versus my alternative right and I
think that is again the beauty of the
red pill in my opinion is the
self-improvement aspect of it and I
think that that's really going to help
more men more so than this conversation
where we just focus on you know yeah
women of terrible we all agree I talk
about it all the time
okay so if a guy makes it to 35 without
getting married you know what his
percentage chance of getting married is
what is it it's like 15 most men if they
do that they don't get married yeah yeah
but what I'm saying is that a man
no I agree with you I agree with you
though with the self-improvement stuff I
just like I'm just more like I look at
it as a prediction I just like this is
what I see in the future this is like
this is my I'm not saying like this is
what I want to happen I'm saying this is
my prediction is that yeah is that
people like it's we're really in a
post-marriage society you know I grew up
with a two-parent home I had nine
siblings it's a good you know it's a
good time but yeah I'm just like what do
I see in the next 10 years more married
people or less married people
do I like and I I just don't see
anything switching until the divorce
laws change that's that's my opinion I
get you on that and I I agree with those
things right I agree I already told you
like I'm for gutting some of the social
safety net that incentivizes this stuff
I'm for you on that from a policy
perspective yeah but from a practical
perspective I don't think that men
should just completely decide hey I
don't want to have a family or I don't
want to try to get married or whatever
like I think that men should have that
goal because that's ultimately what
fulfills a man I don't think that a man
is going to be fulfilled by simply just
going his own way for the rest of his
life doesn't matter how successful he is
I think that there's going to be a part
of him that wishes that he had that
traditional aspect and I don't want to
take men away from that traditionalism I
think where traditional conservatives
kind of fail is they try to tell man hey
rush into a relationship at 18. right 18
years old 19 20 you need to be getting
married you know you need to you know be
starting a family it's like you don't
know anything about life you don't have
any money right you're the least
desirable as a man therefore you know
you're gonna have I mean you might marry
your high school sweetheart or whatever
and that's fine I hope like it
situations like that are beautiful that
happen more often than not back in the
day but not so much today right and I
just feel like the red pill is a little
bit too extreme in regards to the Doom
and Gloom traditional conservatives are
naive I'll tell you I'm in the middle
I'll tell you I'll tell you why I have a
different point of view
because I'll hear this like I'll hear
that like there's something that won't
be fulfilled in a guy that if he doesn't
have a family
and you see I do this divorce
documentary and I interview like men
that sort of did all the stuff you're
saying like they waited till their 30s
to get married they did all like and
they're like but that's the red appeal
thing too that's what they're saying too
right right but I'm saying wait wait so
I'm I'm saying that like a lot of them I
would argue would have been more
fulfilled without a family because of
the system that like they went through
like there are men that I've interviewed
like I I think they're probably gonna
commit suicide in the next year two
years because of like how awful like
everything like this is like men that
have had false accusations against them
in the divorce so now all their all
their friends are against them then they
lose their job then they haven't seen
their kids sometimes they get abuse
allegations the mom like tells the kids
to do abuse alligate like these are this
is serious stuff
um so that's why I when I hear the like
I I guess I have a different point of
view when I hear though like something
won't be fulfilled because I've just
seen and it's not uncommon where guys
get like absolutely wrecked like out of
marriages I think uh David Baker was
helping me with the research on this but
it's like 15 to 20
of all of the people that get married
like the woman maliciously divorces the
guy that means like trying to not let
her him see the kids like like this is
like malicious and so it's like when I
see situations like that it's like I
feel like every guy's kind of got to
decide for himself but I can't really
sell it either way yeah no I mean I I
hear what you're saying I I guess I'm
just saying that I think I'm in the
middle in regards to where I I stand I
just don't think that the Doom and Gloom
message to men is
I don't think that Dash
productive okay uh and I don't think
that being naive about the nature of
women and how they operate in modern
society is good for men either and I'm I
guess I'm in the middle I think I take
the best of what both sides are
preaching and I apply that to my life
personally and that's what I would tell
somebody else if they were a young man
you know trackon or red pill I would say
I would say go with both be in the
middle because I do think there is
something to be said about giving men
expectations that then you know hey you
you know don't don't expect to get
married and you know don't expect to
find a good woman and I think some of
that is just going to lead to you know
men being depressed and lonely and I
think that's just as bad as a woman
being lonely right um even though I
think men handle loneliness probably
better than women do but still I think
that um that's not a good thing and I
want to see more happy successful
relationships and you know big
traditional nuclear families more so
than than not so you know I I think that
the answer somewhere in the middle uh me
personally but again this is not my
wheelhouse I'm not an expert in this I'm
a political commentator I'm not too deep
into the the the the the dating you know
stuff and you know marriage and men and
women stuff but this is just my opinion
on it just based off what I've consumed
um and the information that I have in my
own life experience I just think some of
it is just a little bit too extreme
um and I don't think that the real world
is as bad as what people are making it
out to be even though there are some
terrible situations there are some
absolute terrible situations but men and
women are still getting married men and
women are still dating they're still
seeing each other and you know just like
I say it's all time black and white
people aren't shooting each other and
killing each other in Walmart because
they're black and white a lot of this
stuff is being played up by people who
benefit from the division right even
though there's some truth behind it
right like there's some truth that yes
there are there's racial animosity and
racial division in our society that's
true to it but I think a lot of it is
being played up as a way to benefit
people who again benefit from this type
of division and you know I think that
they're good things with it and there's
also bad things with it I just think
that people gotta take the meat and spit
out the bones you know
I'm curious
um who are you said you're at Trump 2024
as of right now yes okay what what makes
you a trump fan
over like what I like about Trump that's
the other one right what makes me a
trump saint but yeah so what I like
about Trump is that one when I listen to
Trump talk uh I kind of know that that's
how he feels right he's a guy who does
not hide how he feels okay uh even if
that may get him in bad situations at
the very least you know how he feels
versus uh standard politician where he
could say something and you know he
means the exact opposite right or what
he says also what I like about Trump is
that Trump is somebody that in my
opinion is a guy that has
built a brand and a business that in my
opinion is very kind of motivational in
regards to how he has captured a large
group of people in this country and has
served as kind of a like a model right
you know what I'm saying like an Andrew
Tate type of guy right and maybe then I
think about it I would say that is the
rights Andrew Tate like Trump is what
Andrew Tate is except he's just
political right in a sense and that's
what I'm saying like that's what you can
get with somebody who actually can
motivate people and to say hey this is
what I want to be like and then you
throw the political aspect in it in it
as well too you get somebody like Trump
if Andrew Tate came out said I'm
Republican he would essentially be Trump
you know what I'm saying but outside of
the personality stuff outside of kind of
my admiration for him as an individual
in the business and the brand that he's
built and how he carries himself as a
person I think that his policies were
great you know in regards to the economy
uh in regards to how uh unemployment was
at an all-time low is the best economy
we had in a long time uh he didn't get
everything he wanted to get done on the
border done okay but he did you know
start building the wall right he could
have got more done if Republicans
weren't actively fighting against him
along with the Democrats I think that
Trump was amazing on the world stage
okay I think his foreign policy agenda
was probably the best part about Trump
in regards to his ability to keep us out
of Wars okay you have the Abraham
towards what happened in the Middle East
he bought peace there
um he was willing to meet with our
enemies Kim Jong-un he wasn't just
warmongering to be warmongering okay
people criticized him for being butt
buddies with Putin even though that
wasn't necessarily the case okay but he
kept us out of Wars I just think overall
Trump was a great president I know that
this is what we're getting under Trump
and that's basically why I'm supporting
him because I think that he has
unfinished business and um you know I
would like to see him get another term
do you think the election was stolen
last time uh I think that the election
definitely was stolen in the sense that
social media and big Tech definitely
affected the outcome with hiding the
hunter Biden story okay I think that
there is something to be said about
potential voter and election fraud as
well too that happened in some of these
states and Democrats essentially taking
advantage of the pandemic and changing
the rules at the last minute uh and
using the pandemic as a way to make
things more favorable towards them but
in general I think that single day
voting uh making election a holiday and
also paper ballots as well too I think
that if we move towards that then I
think people can move past
you know the whole election
[Laughter]
yeah and and that too yeah and and women
too yeah you're right you're right I
mean more specifically single don't
don't hate on them don't get a married
women credit they vote I think 51-52
they vote more for Republicans right
they're more likely to vote Republican
so I'm not I don't like the you know to
to say always all women more
specifically it's really it certainly is
we would have men would have we would
have won every election uh the last
hundred years Republicans would have won
if it wasn't for the female vote this is
just like yeah I get it I get it but not
all females are overwhelmingly Democrat
voters there are some particularly young
they're married oh there's a there's a
generational shift between under 40 and
over 40. there's absolutely a
generational shift but under 40 they're
they're super liberal yeah yeah but at
the beginning if they if they're they're
married they're more likely to vote more
conservative and uh I think that I would
much rather kind of see more women get
married and under the influence of their
husbands rather than to take away their
right to vote in regards to the solution
in regards to women voting but did it
you would have yeah I get it you
wouldn't predict what you wouldn't
predict that though no I wouldn't
predict that but I'm just saying like in
my ideal World in order to fix the women
voting issue I would say that marriage
is probably the solution like that's
probably the solution to most of
society's problems I don't understand
like as a conservative I can't sit here
and say that most society's problems and
issues have to do with the breakdown of
nuclear family but then not advocate for
the nuclear like like I I have to
advocate for that in some way even even
if I know that yes in modern society
they've essentially disincentivized it
I'm not trying to push people away from
it because I think pushing people away
from it just makes the problem even
worse
no I think I think men kind of do what
they're gonna do regardless I don't
think like I think women are more
influenceable I think men it's kind of
like they're going to do what they're
gonna do I think they're pretty good at
like weighing the pros and the cons of
stuff yeah I mean absolutely I mean I I
agree that me and are going to do what
men are going to do
um and I mean if men want to go their
own way hey you know I don't blame a man
for going his own way I'm just you know
I I just I I just like to see I just I
just wish on the conservative side I
wish I could see more of them advocating
for getting rid of some of these
incentives and I know maybe you do
you're a bit more middle but I wish I
could see like from the conservatives
more like changing like getting rid of
the Duluth model you know what the
Duluth model yeah like stuff like that I
think would be a bit you know I think I
saw I think it might have been wrong to
say it just I saw a republican recently
come out and say oh yeah
um we want child support child support
immediately after birth I was like yeah
you guys are definitely not in touch
yeah like you're not in touch with it
you're not in touch with the like my
like young men right in in the culture
if you're out here proposing
but my man to pay child support even you
know from from conception like I get how
that aligns with the pro-life view that
you know life begins at conception so
therefore I guess you should pay child
support from that perspective but again
it's just like I was saying like some of
these more conservative points of view
that puts all this responsibility on men
don't make sense in modern society
considering how men have less leverage
and I think that a lot of these
conservative politicians are still
thinking so old school in the way that
they think that they're disconnected
from how young men are thinking and I
think that needs to update like Josh
Hawley who I like I mean he's one of my
favorite Senators he's probably he is my
favorite Senator right Josh Hawley
republican from Missouri he says his
thing all the time young men need to
step up you need to step up and Court
these women and take them out on dates
and marry them and show them like that
you're a great man and I'm like boy you
are definitely not in touch with modern
culture because that is not what men are
looking to do anymore right that that's
not men aren't falling for that anymore
where they're going through this whole
process of courting a woman
traditionally to get a non-traditional
outcome or to get a non-traditional
woman so I definitely think that there's
conservative politicians and even some
conservative influencers who have made
who may have found success in their
model in their life but they don't
realize that that doesn't apply to
Restless society and most of them I'll
tell you most of them and I see patterns
this isn't a fun pattern
um are under because the average divorce
is after eight years so most of them are
below that so it's kind of like you're
advocating for something something that
like they'll be like oh this is the path
and I'm like well you haven't even made
it past year eight which is you know and
I don't say this to be like Doom and
Gloom but we see what happened to like
Crowder
and I'm actually I'm gonna I'm gonna by
the time this gets out I have like
really damning evidence on that like no
one else has it yet and it's like it's
gonna change the way people see that
whole case
um that you're saying that Candace is is
wrong oh she had it so wrong she you
don't even understand I got like
hundreds of papers of depositions like I
haven't broken it yet I have to go
finish going through it but I was just
reading it before the interview it
changes like everything and so it's like
he did it the more traditional way and
it's like you know that's why I just
think we're in a post-merage world I
don't like it but
yeah no I again like I said I I I I
concede and I agree with you that in
modern society is definitely not in
men's you know it's definitely not in
our favor and I think seeing that
Crowder situation definitely you know is
kind of evidence that hey even you can
go to traditional route and you can try
to be as traditional as you want but
these are the outcomes right
statistically speaking this is this is
what most likely the outcome but then
again I will leave the door open and say
I don't know how his marriage functioned
I don't know what the you know dynamic
was between him and his wife so it's
hard for me to really say what could
what actually contributed to the divorce
you probably have more information I do
on that yeah yeah you'll you'll at all
next next couple days I don't know but
um thank you for coming on this is fun I
love I love like the conversion between
like the Trad cons like you're kind of
in the middle but like the red pill I
find them fun yeah I think that um yeah
I don't I don't I don't I I think I've
thought about this a lot don't get me
wrong at one point I was really on the
oh red pill like you know yada yada yada
like I was on that but then like you
know again I'm a I'm from a more
traditional background I've seen
traditional families work my family is a
traditional family it's work there's
been ups and downs you know my parents
and whatnot but they still worked it out
um so I think that I understand kind of
The Best of Both Worlds and I think that
the Best of Both Worlds is the solution
moving forward for men and that's what I
would advise is just to take the best of
both and apply to your own life and I
think that's probably the solution I
think I thought the best solution I've
heard was the guy who put everything in
his mom's name
I mean like for example you can you
cannot they say oh you can be in a
relationship with a woman you can go to
church and say hey we're gonna jump to
broom and be married religiously but
we're just not gonna go and get married
you know oh marriage David I'll tell you
actually marriage isn't really the
problem it's um kids there's no way you
can the kids are not the men's kids
they're the women's kids yeah you're not
finagling your way out of that I guess
but yeah I mean not even finagling like
um I just mean like you have no power
control over your kids kid yeah they're
they're not your kids they're hers we've
seen a lot of that when it comes to um
the issue of transitioning kids and
custody rights and you know which parent
uh is going to get custody based off of
uh whether or not they're gonna allow
the kid to transition and there have
been fathers that have just been like in
tears because the mother is pushing He
Go the whole women are evil thing right
you that your own but right you're I
mean yeah the mother pushing the kid to
transition father is helpless to do
anything about it it's one of the
saddest stories in America I don't I
don't say I actually think what I
believe is biblical I think like at a
you know I've even heard Jesse Lee
Peterson talk about this like um he's
got like a church I think
um but I really just think that when
women aren't under the authority of men
we just kind of go nuts that's what I
think so I think that's why you see
these like crazy old ladies I think
that's why we have all these crazy
policies yeah I just think we kind of go
crazy when we don't have a husband or a
father I mean there's a reason we have
like Daddy Issues you know there's a
reason this the stuff is there
yeah I I think I I think I agree with
that I definitely think that uh the
progressivism of religion I think is
definitely or not really but more
Christianity more specifically uh I
think definitely has given too much
leeway to some of these things that
we've allowed to kind of
come into the culture into society and I
think that is kind of the reason why
we're there
um but going back to kind of what I said
before is like yeah well that's why a
lot of these men are kind of moving
towards Islam because they actually are
really more about like Hey we're gonna
stick to what's in our book no guys no
go Catholic yeah that's what they say
but they had to say I mean I'm just
saying I know the Catholics on some BS
too yeah thanks guys
it is what it is I mean you know I it is
what it is but you know um tell them so
you're on Twitter and you're on YouTube
yeah so I'm on Twitter YouTube Facebook
Instagram
um g4man BCP on Twitter on on Instagram
black sort of perspective Facebook
YouTube you can follow me there uh if
you want more political commentary
sometimes I do cultural commentary when
appropriate uh but is more political
stuff so
cool yeah guys go go subscribe to his
channel I'm actually a fan I love your
stuff I I watch it all the time
um and he was he um
he'll cover a lot of like the election
stuff too which is cool so
um guys make sure you like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
also if you want a women shouldn't vote
shirt you want to be the ultimate alpha
male you want women coming up to you
left and right just saying how amazing
you are get yourself a women shouldn't
vote t-shirt today
um The Audacity Network dot store the
link is in the description thank you
guys for watching I'll talk to you next
time
[Music]